the first season of the mandalorian
which launched with the disney plus
streaming platform in 2019
has proven a huge success with both
critics and audiences
as its eight episodes rolled out the
star wars franchise seemed to achieve
something it hadn't in years
a unified fan base being nearly
universally beloved is not something
that comes easily for star wars anymore
the force awakens was a crowd pleaser
but faced criticism for his adherence to
the classic star wars formula
the last jedi proved bitterly divisive
among fans who either
loved or hated it and then there's the
rise of skywalker
i got a bad feeling about this rise of
skywalker
instantly took the dubious distinction
of being the worst reviewed of all the
live-action star wars movies
on top of that there are still the
ongoing debates as to the merits of the
prequel trilogy
and the expanded universe canon all of
this is to say that the mandalorian
success
is important for the franchise's good
name and for the fans
and that means those fans want more
mandalorian and they want it asap
unfortunately one new adventure for our
lone hunter and cub just got delayed
in june 2020 disney and lucasfilm
revealed a full lineup of
mandalorian-related books
designed to save the appetite to fans
eagerly awaiting season 2
which is set to arrive in october 2020
among the promised titles are in-depth
tie-ins like the art of the mandalorian
and the ultimate visual guide a junior
novelization for young adults
a pair of kids story books and an as yet
untitled mandalorian
original novel many of these might seem
insignificant to the average adult
reader
but we're talking about star wars here
every star wars background player and
location
inevitably gets his own action figure or
playset because fans are obsessed about
understanding every square millimeter of
the universe even a junior novelization
might hold some teeny detail for fans to
salivate over
and speculate about obviously though the
two big titles there are the art of the
mandalorian and that's untitled original
novel
both set for a december 2020 release as
of now the art book is still on schedule
but on august 3rd 2020
del rey publishing tweeted that the
mandalorian novels release date
has been moved back to the fall of 2021.
there isn't a lot known about
the original mandalorian novel so far
its author adam christopher
has written books for several other pop
culture licenses
including stranger things dishonored and
elementary
christopher was also written for star
wars before as one of the authors
of star wars from a certain point of
view
a certain point of view yes luke star
wars from a certain point of view
a short story anthology retelling the
events of the original star wars movie
from the perspectives of various
supporting characters as to exactly why
the book is delayed
unfortunately we don't have an
explanation while many might jump to the
conclusion that the release was stymied
by the ongoing pandemic there's been no
indication that that's the case
christopher's comments regarding the
alteration was simple as he tweeted fear
not fellow covert members
the mandalorian will hit the shelves
next year and you will not be
disappointed
fortunately there are other star wars
books still coming out between now
and fall 2021. in addition to the
mandalorian art book
there's alex segura's poe dameron
freefall released on august 4th
segura's book focuses on a teenage poe
the strange relationship he has with his
father
and the early adventures that lead to
his relationship with zory bliss
popular star wars novelist timothy zhan
is returning to the character who made
him such a popular author with star wars
thrawn ascendancy
chaos rising book one slated to arrive
on september 1st
2020 the new novel much like segura's
poe dameron adventure is set in the past
long before thrawn became a famed
general the story follows his first
command
and of course early 2021 will see the
release of star wars the high republic
a major new initiative that will span
both across books
and comics featuring stories set some
200 years before
the skywalker saga basically there's
plenty to chew on in the land of star
wars books
and furthermore the mandalorian second
season is just a scanned few months away
set to stream on disney plus in october
2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you